si todavía no han tratado de escribir su
función fibonacci recursiva realmente
los animo a hacer hagan el intento de
escribirla hagan un serio intento antes
de que revisen este vídeo pero si ya han
hecho el intento o de plano no tienen
ganas de hacerlo bueno creo que pueden
ver el vídeo
entonces tratemos de escribir una
función fibonacci recursiva de acuerdo
con las características que les hablé
cuando lance el desafío de escribir esta
función llamaré a esta función fibonacci
fibonacci y tiene un parámetro n así que
le tendremos que pasar un argumento para
indicarle cuál es el término que
queremos obtener de la sucesión de
fibonacci pero en este caso lo vamos a
ser recursiva mente y veremos que es muy
intuitivo escribir esta función de
manera recursiva es casi mágico y más
tarde veremos que no es necesariamente
la manera más eficiente de hacerlo
cuando escribimos una función recursiva
tenemos que pensar muy bien en el caso
básico el caso básico de la sucesión de
fibonacci bueno en la sucesión de
fibonacci tenemos dos casos básicos el
término 0 y el primer término que los
tenemos por definición así que diremos
yf n es igual a 0 regresamos el término
0 que es 0 y luego decimos el cif n es
igual a 1 si n es igual a 1 entonces
podemos regresar 1 return 1 porque el
primer término en la sucesión de
fibonacci es 1 y aquí es donde pasa algo
casi mágico muy padre el de otra manera
return fibonacci de n 1 esto es
cualquier cosa que nos regresa a la
función fibonacci del término n menos
uno más fibonacci de n
2 y creo que esto debe funcionar y esto
parece mágico porque si decimos que era
el término cero de la sucesión de
fibonacci me regrese a cero si pido el
primer término me regreso
si quiero cualquier otro término er aquí
digo si n no es cero y tampoco es 1
entonces hace este else estamos
asumiendo que el argumento es un número
entero no negativo esto marcaría errores
si ponemos un número negativo y lo que
va a hacer en este ers es tomar el
término anterior y lo va a sumar al
término anterior de la anterior y
podemos tratar de calcularlo por ejemplo
tratemos de hacer fibonacci de 2n no es
0 así que no hacemos esto n no es 1
tampoco hacemos esto así que pasamos a
este else returns regresa el resultado
de la función fibonacci de n menos uno
que es y bonacci de 1 + fibonacci de 2
menos dos fibonacci de 0 y sabemos que
fibonacci de 1 es evaluado como 1 y
fibonacci de 0 es evaluado como 0 así
que esto sería 10 que es igual a 1 y es
correcto y podemos seguir tratando con
fibonacci de 3 debe funcionar porque ya
vimos que fibonacci de 0
d1 y d2 funcionan bien si bonacci de 3
va a llamar a fibonacci de 2 massey
bonacci de 1 y sabemos que fibonacci de
2 es 1 y fibonacci de 1 es uno uno más
uno es 2 entonces vemos que sigue
funcionando y podemos seguir adelante
vamos a salvar esto no es salvado este
archivo y podemos salvarlo como
fibonacci recursivo fibonacci recursivo
es un archivo punto p
dejen de correr el programa lo que hace
cuando corro el programa es definir la
función en mi entorno para que pueda
llamarla desde acá así que déjenme
correr el programa y voy a llamar la
función fibonacci de 4 me regresa la
respuesta correcta si bonacci fibonacci
de 10 55 es correcto fibonacci voy a
tratar algo más simple si buenache de
cero el término cero es cero vemos que
funciona bien y es porque esto de la
recursividad es algo casi mágico y si
quisieran simplificar esto un poco más
podemos revisar muy bien aquí arriba hay
fibonacci de 0 0 y fibonacci de 1 es 1
vemos que en realidad cuando hacemos
fibonacci de cero o fibonacci de 1 el
resultado es ese mismo número entonces
podemos simplificar esto un poco más
siempre asumiendo que estamos pasando un
argumento que es un entero no negativo
podríamos decir algo así como 100 es
igual a 0
si n es igual a cero o n es igual a 1
n es igual a 1 return n vamos a ver si
esto funciona ya simplificamos nuestro
código un poco más
voy a salvarlo y vamos a correr lo voy a
correrlo y tratar de ver que funciona si
bonacci de 10 fibonacci de 10 y sigue
funcionando bien porque en realidad el
término 0 es cero y el primer término es
1 si está funcionando y podemos
simplificar un poco más si decimos aquí
si n es menor que 2 menor que 2 debe
seguir funcionando porque si hacemos 0 o
1 nos regresa a n y para cualquier otro
argumento hace lo que está acá abajo
tratemos de probar esto lo corro y
tratamos con fibonacci fibonacci de 10
ok
vemos que nuestra computadora está
haciendo esto muy rápido pero si
queremos ver todo lo que tiene que hacer
todas las veces que pasa por el código o
sea todas las veces que se llama a la
función fibonacci lo que podemos hacer
es poner aquí un print y cada vez que la
función fibonacci sea
llamada vamos a imprimir fibonacci
fibonacci dos puntos va a imprimir
fibonacci dos puntos y le voy a agregar
a este string a esta cadena de
caracteres el argumento y el argumento
es n y me voy a asegurar de que se vea
como un string y voy a usar esta función
str para que en s vea como parte de la
cadena de caracteres lo que hace esta
función esencialmente es tomar un entero
y convertirlo en string y lo estamos
juntando con el string que escribimos
antes para hacer un string más grande y
vamos a probar esto primero con valores
pequeños así que déjenme correrlo para
definir la función en el entorno y voy a
hacer fibonacci de tres y bonacci de
tres fíjense en esto cuando hago una
llamada fibonacci de tres llama a
fibonacci de dos y si bonacci de uno y
fibonacci de dos llama fibonacci de
unifil bonacci de cero se tienen que
hacer todas estas llamadas a la función
fibonacci para calcular fibonacci de 3
y aquí finalmente nos da el resultado si
hiciéramos algo así como fibonacci de 10
veríamos algo loquísimo vamos a hacerlo
bueno primero vamos a hacer fibonacci
fibonacci de 6 para que vean cuántas
llamadas a la función se tienen que
hacer se hacen todas estas llamadas a la
función para calcular fibonacci de 6 es
un trabajo de la computadora muy intenso
pero la computadora hace todo esto super
rápido en realidad no lo notamos en el
futuro hablaremos un poco más sobre cómo
podemos implementar funciones de
diferentes maneras computacionalmente
intensas